thanks for being here great to see you
again it's so nice to be here yeah in
between the two of you yes he took it to
my reunion very nice enjoy it very much
yeah we had a great time we took our
show to Mexico City and you were kind
enough to come on the program and so you
were there for me trying an entire
monologue in Spanish which you did
amazingly yeah well I got a few laughs I
think they were laughing they were
laughing at the accent I believe but
they still remember you it was really
fun yes really it's two year old kids
with you know redhead look we know yeah
Conan Ito
yeah I was curious so many people have
been talking in this country about the
Super Bowl and the halftime show and how
it's Jennifer Lopez and Shakira and it's
this celebration of you know what yes
well they were saying it was like a
celebration of Latin culture and what
did you think I mean yes I loved it
yeah well Shakira did on that stage
amazing right yeah yeah but the thing is
yeah I've been doing interviews now for
the narcos and and every journalist is
like oh how do you feel you you guys are
so well represented in the Superbowl and
I go like I've never seen anyone moving
their hips like that in Mexico human no
no that's right yeah you don't feel that
represents Mexico doing that no it's
like if you celebrate the German for the
Rolling Stones to be in the in the
Superbowl yeah like what yeah yeah
how does that make sense Latin America
is a gigantic place with so diverse many
countries you know if you put a guy from
Chile in front of a Mexican they might
not understand each other right
so when you say Latino it's not a one
thing right right I was glad they were
there I was glad she was moving like
this I tried at home but I don't
recommend it yeah like I am able to do
it but you are not something yeah we see
anyway I can do it when I'm sitting down
yeah and she sang in Spanish which oh
yeah anything yeah yeah yeah incredible
I thought it was incredible so do you
feel that let's say Mexico in particular
you feel is misrepresented in pop
culture sometimes sometimes it's very
kind from user let's think of yeah like
Speedy Gonzales for example cartoon
character yeah we have a Speedy Gonzales
there yeah we always have it ready yeah
it's always there just in case someone
mentions Speedy Gonzales yeah anyone you
go to another remark ah I will have to
say not one person it's like sounded
like Speedy Gonzales it's like a mouse
in cocaine you know the cocaine passes
through Mexico but it's you guys
consuming it yeah toast mating us our
cocaine we appreciate that